the editor of this morning Martin
Frizzell has been criticized in a
parliamentary Committee hearing
following the comments that he gave to
Sky News when he was asked about the
departure of Philip Schofield and claims
of a toxic culture at the ITV show
here's a clip of what he told us on
Monday
is there a toxic work environment at
this morning the tea was toxic I've
always found toxic is aubergine do you
like aubergine do you is there a toxic
work but do you like aubergine because I
don't like aubergine it's just a
personal thing is there a public work
environment at this morning
well earlier ITV executive Magnus Brooke
was questioned by MPS about his
colleagues comments our arts and
entertainment correspondent Katie
Spencer has been following proceedings
at the select committee everyone wants
to talk about exactly what's been
happening behind the scenes at ITV the
Philip Schofield Scandal and what all
these claims are what what on Earth has
been going on behind the scenes at ITV
and how seriously they have been taking
these claims over toxic workplace and
bullying
um look largely they have stayed away
from talking about this but John
Nicholson the SNP
um uh MP he uh brought up the elephant
in the room if you like he was the one
that specifically has asked in this
meeting look particularly after those
comments that Sky put to Martin Frizzell
yesterday and we got this bizarre
flippant reference to to aubergines of
all things
um how seriously are the ITV bosses
actually taking this and and here's what
he had to say
now we also yesterday that surreal
performance by the editor of the program
who when he was being asked by a
reporter from Sky about bullying on the
program started talking about aubergines
it was surreal and bizarre I think most
people watching that would have thought
this is the person who's responsible for
safeguarding young staff he's being
outrageously dismissive and flippant on
camera about an immensely serious issue
I wouldn't like to be a young staffer
going and talking to that editor about
bullying given that that's the way he
treats the subject matter on camera in
public let me reassure you Mr Nicholson
uh that we take it we take these issues
very seriously and that well I would I
wouldn't endorse what he said uh in fact
I I I I wouldn't use that word uh what
word would you use I I'd certainly say
it was very it was extremely ill-judged
uh to say what he did but look I can
reassure you on behalf of ITV that we do
take all of these allegations very
seriously precisely because we do have a
culture uh uh in which people's conduct
it matters enormously his position
secure after that that's not a question
for for me and it's not a question for
now it is a question that will be put no
doubt to Dame Carolyn McCall who is due
to appear before the culture select
committee not tomorrow but a week on
Wednesday in fact
um yeah I think basically it is clear
that Magnus Brooke has been told to kind
of steer away uh from from talking about
this because the big big boss of ITV in
in Dame Carolyn McCall is the one that
will be answering questions specifically
on the this next week but look MPS and
the general public at large I think want
to see ITV bosses uh taking some
responsibility and hopefully Dame
Carolyn won't be uh talking quite so
flippantly as Martin Frizzell did about
vegetables when she appears next week